the EU and Latin American countries
enjoy solid political ties there's an EU
select summit every two years economy
and trade discussions are on the table
but people are at the heart of their
relationship trade between the two
bloc's is very important a network of
mutually beneficial trade agreements
link the EU with select countries as is
evident from a recent visit to seafood
exhibition in Brussels after the free
trade agreement between Peru and the
European Union about three or four years
ago our exports and imports towards the
European Union are way more fluent and
easier it is quite beneficial the
European Union is the most competitive
market in terms of demanding
certification and demanding compliance
if we comply with the European Union
legislation that means that we comply
with all the relations around the world
on the other side of the Atlantic
European products are widely consumed
total trade between the two bloc's is
around 300 billion euros per year and
the EU is the biggest investor in select
countries with 500 billion euros
the EU select summit were looking to
joint projects with high added value
this future submarine fiber optic cable
will link the European and Latin
American continents will be a major
boost for telecom data transfers and
research and it will allow instant
sharing of large research files for
example these satellite images from a
deforestation monitoring project but the
EU Latin America relationship is not
confined to political and economic
circles it is also about people this is
the court Latino or Latin American
student house on the campus of the
University of Leuven in Belgium it's
party time
Celine a Belgian student went on an
Erasmus exchange to Peru - mmmm
seitan good girl and continues up my
nose like a stab in the loop are comin
hermano my yo-yo sent a message across
at the same time in Buenos Aires Sophie
is also on an Erasmus exchange so I grew
the patients this year when I their
student exchanges are the best way to
achieve long-lasting people-to-people
contacts in order to push forward new
ideas and have a say at the political
level an organised and vibrant civil
society has a major role to play EU and
select organizations came together
earlier this year to prepare their
message to the leaders o beneficial
operation for the capital of occupied
Espace Wikipedia or associative is not a
more personal country mercy will parent
a felony digital politic a fan of arenas
Siddhartha's own salon sobre la
co-author a little
you know we believe that both regions
are facing similar problems in terms of
economic crisis and in terms of
shrinking space for civil society
organizations but at the same time we do
believe that we have more and more
alternative civil society movements
raising from the real concerns from
citizens in both regions we do expect
that our heads of the states listen to
our concerns back in Leuven University
Louis Pineda a researcher Ecuador
presents his thesis I think the benefits
are moot well you come and compete in a
very high level with another students we
are not a scientist so you are exposed
to a lot of international interaction
but at the same time if you realize what
makes this diverse environment and that
practical if the people who's living
here partnership is the key word of the
EU select summit to develop the economy
joint projects more contacts and with
citizens at the heart of the leaders
priorities